qu'une partie de la population française
n'est plus peur de la police alors que
des messages à caractère raciste écrit
par des forces de l'ordre sur les
réseaux sociaux font l'objet d'une
enquête des tensions sur fond de crise
sanitaire et alors que la crise
économique se profile
quelle est la réponse de la droite face
à ces défis du moment
comment être une opposition crédible une
alternative à emmanuel macron quand des
listes l air est en marche fusionnent
dans plusieurs grandes villes pour les
municipales on va parler de tout ça avec
vous christian jacob à mes côtés pour
vous interroger damien fleurot de ces
news et cécile cornudet deseco bonjour à
vous deux jeux etc
damien fleurot qui va vous poser la
première question sur les manifestations
de ces derniers jours
oui bonjour christian jacob est joliment
des rassemblements et hier pour dénoncer
ces violences commises par des forces de
l'ordre alors ces rassemblements qui
était interdit en raison de la crise
sanitaire milk ont quand même eu lieu et
qui sont globalement déroulées dans le
calme
est ce que vous comprenez la colère
l'émotion de ces manifestants d'abord en
france la police elle rassure ne fait
pas peur elle rassure et moi je voudrais
apporter si tout mon soutien aux forces
de police à nos forces de sécurité à nos
gendarmes
on les a vus sur tous les fronts la
lutte contre le terrorisme
mais au moment dé des mouvements sociaux
au moment du coc vide où on les a
envoyés en première ligne sans
protection sans masque donc d'abord
saluer leur leurs actions ensuite sur
cette manifestation
bien sûr que la lutte contre le racisme
c'est au peu pas trop ou une cause plus
noble que les contrôler mais violent
mais mais ça n'existe pas des violences
policières en france et c'est un
mensonge
ça n'existe pas on a vu des violences de
manifestants mais jamais de violences
policières en france du racisme dans la
police même si ce n'est pas tout la
police il ya du racisme en france comme
dans beaucoup d'autres pays comme dans
tous les pays et faut lutter contre le
lot le racisme et le sanctionner mais on
n'a pas une police racistes en france ça
n'existe pas
moi je suis fier de notre de notre
police et j'ai été profondément choqué
par les les slogans qu'on a vu qu'on a
pu entendre on entendu la police qui a
été prêté deux de raciste on a vu
d'ailleurs par ses prétendus
manifestants antiracistes s'en prendre à
des policiers noirs les traité de vendu
s'en prendre à des policiers d'origine
maghrébine de dire qu'il jouait les
arabes de service ces prétendus
manifestants antiracistes tenir et ce
qui va peut-être encore le plus le plus
choqué fac est le plus choquant c'est
face à ces insultes à l'égard de notre
police le silence assourdissant du
président de la république et du premier
ministre
ils étaient où nous deux têtes de
l'exécutif ou s il était au moment où là
la police nationale et humiliés et
insulté de cette manière on n'entend
rien ils doivent prendre la parole le
premier ministre et le chef de l'état
pour vos christian jacob
mais c'est paris je doive c'est qu'ils
auraient dû mais comment on peut laisser
notre police nationale se faire insulter
de cette manière et pas un mot du
président de la république pas un mot du
premier ministre c'est ça la réalité ou
aujourd'hui tous alpes et on va on va
écouter tout de suite ce que disait
christophe castaner alors vous le dit
christian jacob la police n'est pas
raciste mais il peut y avoir parfois du
racisme dans la police et voilà ce qu'on
disait dans le journalisme ou dans la
classe politique
vous avez la france entière et dont
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur lui a pris la parole c'était
mercredi au sénat après la première
manifestation qui avait rassemblé du
coup plus de 20000 personnes mardi soir
à paris
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot est compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction
alors christophe castaner a mis cette
doctrine en application en saisissant la
justice le parquet de paris a d'ailleurs
ouvert une enquête pour injures
publiques à caractère raciste et
provocation publique à la haine raciale
visant un groupe facebook qui regroupe à
peu près huit mille policiers et
gendarmes on trouve des propos racistes
sexistes aussi vous êtes d'accord avec
le ministre il ne faut plus rien laisser
passer pour que la police ne fassent
plus peur et ne soit plus mis en cause
mais la police
rappeur en france par la police
certaines personnes me rassure elle me
rassure
las il ya eu dérapage si ces actes sont
avérées la justice est saisie et les
sanctions tomberont et il est normal que
les sanctions tombent mais mais mais
simplement on assiste là un amalgames
invraisemblables et encore une fois que
le gouvernement et l'exécutif au plus
haut niveau ne ne s'exprime pas ne
disent rien pour défendre l'honneur de
nos policiers
une fois on était content de les trouver
et en est heureux de les avoir dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
on est heureux de les avoir au moment
des mouvements sociaux des saccages
qu'il ya plus à ce silence du couple
exécutif justement observé faire c'est
un laisser faire c'est d'abord l'esprit
on a froissé une partie de la population
de certaines catégories de français
comme s'il voulait qu'on voit qu'on a
aussi le gouvernement enfin le
gouvernement a perdu pied en matière de
délinquance on est une explosion de la
de la délinquance qui se vérifie
aujourd'hui et et cette volonté de
chercher à aller dans le sens du vent ou
de ceux qui braillent le plus fort je
crois que tout ça est et est regrettable
est vraiment moi ça m'a ça m'a choqué ce
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas qu'un
président de la république puisse se
taire on a vu jacques chirac eux
quittaient un stade de foot
lorsque la marseillaise était sifflée la
halle de police milliers insultez pas un
mot du président un mot du premier mich
quand il était ministre l'intérieur
nicolas sarkozy il avait toujours les
deux discours il disait je soutiens les
forces de l'ordre mais je n'accepterai
aucun dérapage
est ce que s'est passé ce double
discours qui le gouvernement essaye de
théniers c'est comme ça que doit se
comporter un ministre l'intérieur
c'était la force et la légitimité
nécessaire
là on est quand même très loin nicolas
sarkozy évoque la bourse était pas on
peut pas imaginer la moindre comparaison
plus entendre de ces manifestants c'est
quand même beaucoup de monde mais dans
la met encore une fois en afrique dans
le pacifique avait attendait
les insultes les policiers noirs qui se
font traiter de vendus par des soi
disant vous me les tensions nées la
magnifique mais on fait partie des
manifestants c'était le cas on les a
entendu ces propos on entendu des chants
qui appellent à la révolution et à
prendre les armes on a entendu aussi ça
dans ses manifestations et une
manifestation interdite de 20 mille
personnes et qui finalement est
autorisée sans interpellation enfin 18
interpellations je crois sur une
manifestation de 20000 personnes je vous
rappelle que on est à un moment où
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est toujours
en place ou les restaurants ne peuvent
pas fonctionner ou les bars ne
fonctionne pas ou les
le nombre d'élèves par école est limité
et là on n'a pas misé personne qui sera
s'il ya des manifestations dans le monde
entier
la mort de georges floyd a suscité une
émotion mondiale pour c'est qu'il aurait
fallu dire manifestation interdite et où
on exfiltre tous les manifestants qui
voulaient manifester sont le
majoritairement pacifiques mais mêlée
tournée sous état d'urgence à ces
restaurateurs qui ne peuvent pas
fonctionner aujourd'hui
et là on autorise vingt mille personnes
et permettez moi de vous dire que la
comparaison avec les états unis n'a pas
de sens on est sûr de systèmes réussite
totalement différent on est aux états
unis dans un état fédéral avec des
policiers qui sont dans l'immense
majorité où la quasi totalité sous
l'autorité de mer ou d'eau ou de chérif
élus nous on est dans une france avec
une police unifiée avec des écoles de
police avec un code de déontologie y
avait qu une une police qui correspond à
l'image de notre société dans sa
diversité
mais vous savez si les toits des
bâtiments au pouvoir vous faisiez quoi
pour pour maintenir l'interdiction à
partir du moment où lorsqu'une
manifestation est interdite
on applique l'interdiction c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est le
gouvernement qui interdit les
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
et qui autorise une manifestation de 20
mille femmes
mais quand même un peu d'incompréhension
on voit bien que vous considérez vous le
disiez tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de
violence policière est ce que vous avez
vu peut-être comme beaucoup de français
pensent qu'être ces images tombe
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux et même
dans l'est dans les journaux télévisés
de l'interpellation du jeune gabriel 14
ans a bondi fin mai pour un vol de
scooter
ce jeune garçon de 14 ans a fini à
l'hôpital vous considérez vraiment qu'il
n'y a jamais de violence peser les
enquêtes ouvertes lorsqu'il y a à chaque
fois qu'il y a eu et il y en a à chaque
fois qu'il ya un dérapage à chaque fois
qu'il y à une faute systématiquement
igpn et saisi systématiquement il ya
sanction est donc bien évidemment quand
il y a des rapports et les sanctionner
et c'est normal et c'est l'honneur de la
police qu'il le soit alors justement
quand il y as dérapage il est sanctionné
souvent à base de vidéo qui aide à
l'identification et dans votre famille
politique eric ciotti le député les
républicains a déposé une proposition de
loi visant justement à ne plus permettre
l'identification de ces forces de
l'ordre dans la diffusion d'image sur
les réseaux sociaux pour les protéger
dit-il parce qu'ils peuvent être parfois
ensuite embêté à leur domicile notamment
est ce que finalement c'est pas une
certaine forme de censure non c'est
tellement content moi je donne raison à
eric ciotti et je soutiens sur 7 sur
cette proposition le floutage il vaut
pour les réseaux sociaux pas pour une
enquête de justice
à partir du moment où il ya violence il
y a il y à enquête
et s'il ya enquête bien évidemment que
le floutage n'a pas lieu
c'est simplement te rappeler qu'en
france la justice a n'est pas dans la
rue ni sur les réseaux sociaux on a des
juges indépendants qui rendent la
justice est d'ailleurs signé cette
justice de l'émotion justement je pense
dans la zone et à droite ce n'est pas
les les réseaux sociaux qui sont quand
même un déversement de violence dans
bien des cas qui ont aussi des atouts
mais la réalité c'est qu'en mai
à partir du moment où il ya une enquête
il est évident que le floutage n'a pas
lieu mais mettons nous à la place de ces
policiers qui se font prendre à partie
leur famille également lorsqu'ils
rentrent chez eux on le fait d'ailleurs
pour le pour leur aide et pour un
certain nombre de 2,2 forces spéciales
et donc c'est normal moi c'est non
seulement ça ne me choque pas mais je
pense que c'est une bonne mesure de
protection mais qui ne vont pas pour une
enquête bien évidemment on marque une
pause et on se retrouve dans un instant
avec christian jacob
nous sommes toujours avec christian
jacob président de l air après la crise
sanitaire c'est la crise économique qui
se profile avec une priorité aujourd'hui
pour l'exécutif protéger l'emploi
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
était en visite mardi dans une start up
en écoute l'emploi devient à nouveau la
première préoccupation des français
il promit défi que nous avons arleux
j'emploie il faut les protéger dans
toute la mesure du possible mais il faut
aussi penser en créer de nouveaux
l'exécutif va présenter son plan de
relance à la rentrée alors en plus des
plans sectoriels qui sont égrenés au fur
et à mesure pour l'automobile le
tourisme et bientôt l'aéronautique
l'allemagne a fait un choix différent
c'est un plan global de 230 milliards
d'euros est ce que la méthode française
est la bonne moi je ne crois pas en lui
avons dit nous avons soutenu un certain
nombre de mesures qui est qui qui vont
dans le bon sens même et je pense qu'il
y a urgence à agir
et c'est seulement une question de
calendrier qui ont pris ce qu'on fera
pas que pas que
mais il ya urgence à agir parce qu'une
entreprise a besoin de lisibilité sur la
sur l'action publique
et puis par rapport à l'allemagne
faisait référence à l'allemagne
la situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui c'est que on a le
le défi qu'on arrive enfin la fin de
2019 le déficit public le plus élevé de
la de la zone euro le déficit commercial
plus bord de l'union européenne une
explosion de la de la dette ainsi
confinés
oui mais enfin quand même une explosion
de la terre 2010
avant ça on dépasser 100% de
de taux de dette on a le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires le plus élevé
de l'union européenne
on a le 25e taux de croissance en europe
c'est ça la réalité des trois ans
d'action d'edouard philippe et de et
d'emmanuel macron donc on aborde la
crise dans cette situation là et donc
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y à la
nécessité de mettre en place un plan
très rapidement c'est les propositions
nous avons fait aux républicains de
milliards d'euros oui c'est ça à 250
milliards d'euros
avec du coup des suppressions de charges
pour les pme tva a baissé sur les 1000
produits de première nécessité et la
transformation du jour glacial en
allégements de charges et pour pépon la
tva abaissée pour la restauration n'ont
pas délaissé le prix l'hôtellerie de la
restauration
mais pour reconstituer des marbres moi
j'ai eu cette expérience lorsque j'étais
ministre de des pme on voit bien que sur
une entreprise
l'élément déterminant c'est la
reconstitution du fonds de roulement
or là il n'y a plus de fonds de
roulement donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
plutôt que faire du report de charges il
faut faire de l'annulation de deux
charges le faire très rapidement et
faire en sorte que les marges se
reconstitue parce que dès qu'une
entreprise retrouve son fonds de
roulement
il ya se recréer une dynamique et c'est
ça vraiment l'urgence et tout notre plan
est basé là dessus avec un double enjeu
c'est à dire à la fois la nécessité de
conforter les entreprises de recréer ces
fonds de roulement et en même temps des
actions sur le pouvoir d'achat le leur
on vole avec ce plan créé un jacob vous
n'avez pas tournée
la page d'un dogme jusqu'ici dans votre
famille le sérieux budgétaire où
l'orthodoxie budgétaire comme certains
disent parce que c'est un plan qui est
très coûteux par exemple cette mesure de
la baisse de la tva pour les 1000
produits de première nécessité ça va
coûter combien
globalement le plan c 250 milliards c
est sur cet essai mesure qu'il sait
l'excédent pour à titre de comparaison
c'est l'excédent commercial annuel de
l'allemagne voilà donc on n'est pas non
plus on est sur des des chiffres qui
vont ramener aussi à cette réalité
mais il y a effectivement un volet
pouvoir d'achat qui est qui qui est
important parce qu'on voit bien qu'on a
des salaires relativement bas on ne peut
pas si vous augmentez les salaires de
laisser filer la dépenses publicitaires
augmentent les salaires
vous vous déstabiliser la compétitivité
des entreprises vous affaiblissez d'où
des différentes idées à la fois sur la
la participation que l'on veut vraiment
remettre en place sur l'augmentation du
ti s'est passé les entreprises enfin moi
de bénéfices donc la mort met d'accord
mais il est important de la deûle à
mettre en place pour accompagner les
augmentations de salaire et faire en
sorte que les salariés participent aux
résultats de l'entreprise et le deuxième
élément c'est aussi le temps de travail
c'est l'annualisation du temps de
travail passé de 1600 heures à 1800
heures sur des accords d'entreprise pas
d'accords nationaux au plus près
possible du bon de commande
parce que c'est dans l'entreprise que
l'on sait si effectivement le carnet de
commandes se remplit ou si ce vide et
c'est là qu'il faut pouvoir ajuster et
quand on on augmente on annualise le
temps de travail et qu'on augmente ça se
traduit par une augmentation du salaire
des salariés et en même temps par un
gain de compétitivité de l'entreprise
sur le coût du travail
christian jacob ce qui inquiète
particulièrement dans cette crise et
l'impact sur les jeunes les jeunes qui
doivent rentrer sur le marché du travail
qu'est ce que vous proposez pour que la
jeunesse ne soit pas la génération
sacrifiée comme l'a dit la mesnie du
travail ne les punit co2 deux mesures
qui me semble très très importante à
développer il y a effectivement dans les
trois semaines qui viennent
sept cent mille jeunes qui arrivent sur
le sur le marché du travail dans un
contexte économique très tendu avec du
chômage partiel donc c'est effectivement
très compliqué
deux mesures que l'on propose c'est
d'abord de relancer de manière très
forte l'apprentissage est une mesure
très concrète c'est à dire la prise en
charge de toutes les charges patronales
pour toutes les entreprises qui
recrutent des apprentis est la deuxième
mesure qui une prise en charge dans le
l'esprit du chômage partiel sur les six
premiers mois dans bausch par par l'état
et ensuite une baisse de charge à
condition de l'entreprise fasse un cdi
aux jeunes c'est à dire c'est la
contrepartie de la pérennité blanc sur
l'apprentissage christian jacob le
gouvernement propose huit mille euros d'
aide à une entreprise qui prend la jeune
apprentie majeur 5000 euros pour un
mineur ça c'est une décision que vous
salue et du cou
non parce que là non je pense que le nom
le que le système de primes n'est pas
bon ça crée un effet d'aubaine immédiat
moi je préfère qu'on s'installe dans la
durée sur l'apprentissage avec la prise
en compte des charges sociales
c'est-à-dire dans le prolongement de ce
qui est de ce qui a pu être fait sur les
sur les bas salaires la de le faire
totalement pour les toutes les
entreprises qui recrutent des jeunes en
apprentissage jeunes ou moins jeunes
d'ailleurs christian jacob un mot sur
l'initiative de d'emmanuel macron dose
un esprit peut-être de concorde
nationale
le chef de l'état demande des
propositions au président de l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi au président du
sénat qui est de votre famille politique
est ce que vous vous saluer l'initiative
présidentielle ou es ce que vous avez
été surpris un peu comme gérard larcher
pour le pour le moins surpris on est
encore sur l'iccn coup de coude comme
hier si le président de la république
croyez pas à cette idée non le moindre
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que le
passé ne plaide pas pour lui et ensuite
tu vas dire on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
il est perdu en manque de repères
surtout donc il faut gagner du temps
rien n'est perdu selon bah écoutez c'est
quand même la réalité
moi je suis incapable de dire quelle est
la ligne du président de la république
on a vu alors on peut pratiquer la
fixerait début juillet paye sans doute
pas opéra oui peut-être que le début
juillet la foire à voir des choses que
vous avez vous sentez vous voulez être
consultés et l'a finalement il ne l'a
jamais été je suis président du premier
parti d'opposition ne jamais rencontrer
président de la république une écoute et
ça sans doute que pour lui ça ne
représente pas beaucoup d'intérêt
ceci étant on a des propositions qui
sont sur la table on le fait à chaque
fois on a toujours été dans une
opposition qui a été constructive en
permanence simplement prendre les
exemples
oui quand j'ai quitté la présidence du
début du groupe parlementaire sur
l'ensemble des textes présentés nous
avons voté 40% des textes par ce non pas
qu'on s'y retrouver complètement mais
qu'on considérait qu'un certain moment
il allait dans le bon sens inverse n'a
jamais été près les propositions de
l'opposition qui ont été reprises
arrivée à matignon par le premier
ministre oui oui c'est très bien mais
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il en est
sorti
est ce qu'une proposition que nous avons
faite a été repris dans les propositions
de la droite
et là c'est l'affolement donc il faut
trouver quelque chose dans les
propositions à moitié notamment donner
plus de compétences aux collectivités
locales
alors c'était déjà votre votre volonté
avant la crise du coroner virus est
encore plus a fortiori après cette crise
est ce que vous dites au chef de l'état
effectivement c'est le moment d'avoir un
état non moins centralisé ou moins
concentré oui proposition très forte
d'ailleurs qui a été fait est incarnée
par par françois baroin qui est qui le
fait au titre à la fois de la ms mais
également de l'association des régions
de france et des départements de france
on a vu dans cette période de crise
combien les collectivités territoriales
ont joué un rôle important c'est qu'ils
ont été beaucoup plus réactive que ne
l'était l'état beaucoup plus efficaces
aussi on l'a vu sur les sur les masques
on a vu sa proximité avec les artisans
les commerçants les indépendants qui
n'avait pas été vraiment parce que la
majorité de ces collectivités sont de
votre famille mais c'est la réalité la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles ont
été efficaces et qu'ils ont pallié les
défaillances de l'état et l'état s'est
enfermé dans un premier temps sur ses
mensonges
souvenons nous qui a pas besoin de la sq
il n'y a pas besoin de tests et puis
après on a dû rétropédaler s'il y a des
masques qui ont été distribués merci aux
collectivités territoriales c'est elle
qui se sont mobilisés et donc je pense
que comme le disait aurait dit à un
moment il ya longtemps que c'était dans
les propositions de la droite mais je
pense que l'or la crise l'a mis
davantage en exergue de permettre
beaucoup plus d'autonomie fiscale aux
collectivités et une répartition des
compétences
on marque une pause on se retrouve dans
un instant et de christian jacob a parlé
des municipales
nous sommes toujours avec christian
jacob le président de l air alors
christian jacob dont trois semaines sous
réserve que la situation sanitaire le
permettent les français vont aller voter
pour le second tour des municipales dans
les quelques 5000 communes un peu moins
qu'ils n'ont pas élu leur mère dès le
premier tour est ce que vous croyez que
les français iront voter ce 28 juin
malgré les incertitudes sanitaires et la
proche des vacances je pense que oui je
pense que oui le fait qu'il y ait trois
semaines de campagne déjà ça va
permettre de créer davantage de
mobilisation et je pense sur une
mobilisation plus forte
effectivement mais pas d'inquiétude on
voit dans certaines on en a toujours
bien évidemment des ti a lancé un site
pour faciliter oui à la raison à sion il
faut mobiliser au maximum et
dans les 2e tour c'est toujours comme
cela est là dans cette situation de
crise encore plus c'est pour ça que nous
nous avons été force de proposition en
proposant qu'il puisse y avoir plusieurs
procurations qui fût ce pour être porté
par une personne moi j'avais même avancé
l'idée d'un vote par par correspondance
de faciliter justement dire après les
municipales a dit que ce qu'on pouvait
le faire avant si oui le vote par
correspondance n'est pas très compliqué
on le fait pour les allées les français
de l'étranger
il suffit de mettre une enveloppe t dans
le dans l'enveloppent de propagande
électorale c'est quelque chose qui était
tout à fait possible à faire le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu faire voilà
pour des raisons électoralistes ou
pensée pour ses pas on verra mais j'ai
trouvé surprenant que tous ces
propositions soient refusés maintenant
bon ce qu'il faut c'est mobiliser et
mais aussi par françois bayrou qui est
membre de la majorité commencent était
suffisamment christian jacob quelles
sont vos ambitions justement pour pour
ce second tour
on voit que votre famille politique
n'est pas forcément en si bonne position
dans certaines villes comme marseille
comme toulouse
votre ambition pour ce sera tout d'abord
là avant de parler du deuxième tour j'ai
dire un point de constats sur le premier
tour
le premier tour tout d'abord pour nous
c'est une grande victoire
c'est à dire si on prend les les mairies
élu au premier tour sur les villes de
plus de 9000 habitants
56% des villes ont des mères les
républicains ou des mères ou d'aimer
rallier donc pour gérer mon forte pour
la première fois deux haïtiens ans
on renoue avec la victoire après une
présidentielle où pour la première fois
de notre histoire on n'était pas présent
au deuxième tour après des législatives
ou non seulement on reste dans
l'opposition mme on divise par deux
notes nombre de députés et après l'échec
le plus cuisant qu'on n'ait jamais aux
élections européennes on renoue avec la
victoire et on a deux tiers des maires
élus au premier tour victoire contre
auxerre et nice
si vous perdez masse colossale à gauche
je continue
je continue on a d'abord c'est ce
premier résultât deuxième élément
intéressant sur ce deuxième tour on voit
qu'on a une reconstitution du bloc de
gauche alors très très hétéroclite mais
puisque ça va de l'extrême gauche la
france insoumise les verts le ps et les
radicaux de gauche
mais quand même ce bloc on le voit
renaître de manière très éclatée mais
quand même ensuite troisième élément
c'est un effondrement sans précédent et
une sanction très violente pour la
république en marche tous ceux qui ont
été sur les colleurs la république en
marche c'est une sanction très forte
et puis quatrième point et dernier point
d' analyse c'est l'incapacité du front
national à avoir un enracinement
territorial alors qu'ils avaient nourri
de très fortes ambitions sur ces
élections alors vous parlez de la
république en mars alors vous parlez
d'un bloc de gauche
est-ce qu'on peut mettre la république
en marge d'un bloc de droite sachant
qu'il ya plusieurs grandes villes où vos
listes ont fusionné c'est le cas dans le
5e arrondissement à paris strasbourg
alors sur le sodium jeux wii le 5e
arrondissement finalement la candidat
demain excellèrent maire du 5e qui est à
la base chez vous finalement été parfait
avec deux élus locaux et qui finalement
va soutenir rachida dati au second tour
mais si on a strasbourg lyon aussi vous
êtes avec la république en marche
même s'il a le 8 mars n'est pas très
favorable
bordeaux la république en marche
soutient le maire sortant elle est
clermont ferrand vous êtes ensemble face
à la gauche
il ya aussi le cas à tous aurillac ya
quand même quelques exemples sur les
villes de
de plus de 30 mille deux cent soixante
treize villes de plus de 30 mille
habitants en france il ya six villes où
il ya des accords locaux techniques
souvent je vous dise sur les villes de
plus de 30 mille habitants qui sont les
villes importantes an en france
273 ville sur 35 mille communes donc
c'est important
il y a six villes où il y a des
désaccords locaux techniques qui selon
passé on l'a vu à lyon d'ailleurs avec
un désengagement souvent de la
république en marche par exemple à lyon
ils ont retiré les les investir avec ses
coudes et ce sont des accords locaux qui
ont dépassé un contexte particulier a
lyon par exemple ce sont sur la
métropole
l'ensemble des élus territoriaux des
maires qui ont décidé de s'opposer à un
risque de l'extrême gauche de l'alliance
de la france insoumise avec les verts
les amis de monsieur mélenchon pour
diriger la métropole de lyon les élus
territoriaux ont dit à partir du moment
où gérard que l'on n'est pas candidat et
que le rassemblement se fait autour de
françois noël buffet qui est notre
candidat
les républicains nous sommes prêts à
faire l'alliance pour nous opposer à
l'extrême gauche
c'est un accord local
moi je m'en satisfais mais ça n'est en
aucun cas un accord politique sur sur
strasbourg
nous sommes à peu près dans une
configuration comparable à strasbourg
l'accord se fait encore une fois c'est
un accord local avec les élus
territoriaux qui disent sur la métropole
de strasbourg nous avons beaucoup de
villes de droite il y à un risque là
aussi de l'extrême gauche et des verts
là aussi les amis de monsieur mélenchon
et et les verts qui risque de faire une
majorité et donc les élus territoriaux
10 nous si on a six lits à des élus les
républicains à strasbourg nous pourrons
diriger la métropole de strasbourg et
c'est dans cet esprit là que ça se fait
encore une fois c'est dans six villes
mais jacob vous dites que ce sont des
accords techniques
il ya quelques mois si on reprend vos
paroles c'était la fin du mois d'août je
crois vous disiez qu'il ne fallait pas
qu'ils aient de marcheurs sur les listes
a l'air parce que les élus dans les
conseils municipaux voteront pour les
sénatoriales
vous n'avez plus peur que du coup
et vous perdiez des voix aux
sénatoriales ou alors si certaines
villes on peut perdre si on n'a pas le
soutien la république en marche
je veux juste rappeler 273 ville civile
6 où il y a ces accords techniques qui
sont aussi des accords de majorité et
donc je fais confiance à nicolas florian
quitte par exemple dans le cas oui à
bordeaux nantes dans le cadre de deux de
l'accord technique qui l'a qu'il a passé
la liste de nicolas florian la liste est
républicain gardera la majorité absolue
et donc je pense que il y aura un pacte
de confiance qui sera établi au moment
des sénatoriales mais bon voilà les les
résultats tels qu'ils sont là on attend
le deuxième tour avec impatience avec
des villes importantes en ans je faisais
référence à paris pour nous paris c'est
un c'est un enjeu important
si vous avez vu le sondage du journal de
dimanche son latin oui vous avez encore
de l'espoir pour que rachida dati
puissions portant des oui oui très
clairement parce que regarder les
progressions rachida dati progresse de
10 points
dans le sondage anne hidalgo progresse
de quatre points et est aujourd'hui dans
cette forme de triangulaire en quelque
sorte avec la république en orge qui
sérieusement à paris peut imaginer un
instant qu agnès buzyn devienne maire de
paris je prend absolument personne y
compris elle-même y compris cccc premier
ses premiers soutiens personne n'y croit
donc les choses à paris son simple choix
on considère que madame hidalgo est une
excellente merde à paris qui a pas de
problèmes de délinquance qui a pas de
problème de saleté qui a pas de
problèmes de transport et à ce moment là
les gens qui sont satisfaits de la
gestion de madame hidalgo voteront pour
elle mais si ça n'est pas le cas la
seule alternative c'est rachida de
vérité les électeurs daniel du zend en
marche a noté rachid et j'appelle
l'ensemble des parisiens à se mobiliser
autour des des listes de rachida dati
christian jacob projetons nous
dans les prochains scrutins notamment
les élections départementales vous nous
avez parlé pour ces élections
municipales de d'accords techniques de
pacte de cas par cas mais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire il n'y aura pas
d'accord avec la république en marche
pour les départementales et peut-être
plus tard pour les régionales les
résultats
l'effondrement total la république en
marche sur les territoires c'est quand
même une des données essentielles
aujourd'hui fort heureusement il n'était
pas présent
rappelez-vous le moment où monsieur
castaner nous expliquer que dans trente
cinq mille de france 35 mille villes de
france partout il y aurait des candidats
aux marchés on verrait ce qu'on verrait
et est effectivement pris de panique
à quelques jours du premier tour ils ont
annoncé un objectif de dix mille
conseillers municipaux sur 530 me
conseillers municipaux d'hier un
objectif de moins de 2%
bon pour une fois qu'ils avaient un
objectif réaliste ils vont même pas
l'atteindre
donc tout ça n'engage pas effectivement
à être sur des alliances moi je reste
sur la même sur la même position
nous irons sur nos couleurs après dans
les majorités départementales commun
régional où on l'a vu partout il y a
encore et il ya des compositions que ce
ton mais ce sera sous les couleurs de l
heure ils auront peut-être plus de
conseillers municipaux
grâce à vous grâce aux fusions dans les
villes n'auraient même si on peut avoir
beaucoup d'espoir ils vous disent avait
pris 7 pour une fois que c'était
raisonnable un objectif de 2% et b vont
pas le latin ils auront moins de 2 % des
conseillers municipaux en france voilà
la réalité dans marche matin c'était une
punition des élections municipales pour
monsieur macro c'est une punition
cinglante christian jacob françois
baroin dont vous êtes proche dira ses
intentions pour la présidentielle à
l'automne il est aujourd'hui il fait une
interview au journal du dimanche il a
été très discret pendant la crise
est ce qu'un futur candidat à la
présidentielle peut se permettre de ne
pas monter au front
dans un tel moment que celui que vient
de livres
la france je crois que ce moment que
nous venons de vivre imposait du sérieux
de la retenue et de la rigueur
c'est à dire ici d'une telle crise
sanitaire
le silence était aussi l'efficacité
appel de françois baroin dans sa ville
de troyes et à la tête de l'aef
on a vu le rôle qu'ont joué les maires
et et la mmf a été en accompagnement en
permanence des collectivités
territoriales donc ça d'abord été cela
le rôle n'était pas de s'agiter pour
gêner ou pour handicapés l'action au
moment où on était confronté à ces
grandes crises sanitaires viendra le
moment des projets politiques et l'a
fait confiance à françois baroin pour
être capable de ce2 se verront élus de
droite ont elles entrent mais quand même
particulièrement je pense qu'il a eu
particulièrement raison il y a des
moments où la nation de se rassembler et
quand on était face à une crise
sanitaire comme celle là c'était ce
moment va venir le moment de tirer les
enseignements et nous avons d'ailleurs
des commission denquête qui démarre à
l'assemblée nationale et on va pouvoir
et au sénat et on va pouvoir voir les
choses est transparente
je souhaiterais moi d'ailleurs qu'à
l'occasion de ces commission denquête
dans les meilleurs délais madame busin
soit auditionnée elle qui ne jouera pas
avant les municipales
mais c'est scandaleux n'attendez pas
très républicain l'assemblée sondage
mettant des moindres concerne je
souhaite qu'elle puisse être auditionné
très rapidement ce soit avant le désert
qui s'épanouit avons décidé de la
commission denquête aujourd'hui c'est
monsieur richard ferrand le premier
ministre c'est richard fermé de la même
famille et l'urgence de cette audition
si le travail de la collation et les
parlementaires devaient durer jusque mai
en vue du mois de juillet l'urgence
qu'il l'a décidé c'est le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui a décidé
l'urgence qui a décidé de transformer la
mission d'information très rapidement en
commission denquête c'est lui qui prend
cette décision
alors on va installer une commission
denquête mais surtour n'auditionnent pas
madame du g20 attendait d'après les
déclarations de m d'usain les
déclarations du premier ministre et du
gouvernement
si on fait cette commission denquête
alors d'une part on va nous essayer de
créer un espèce de truc baroque à une
nouvelle commission pour brouiller les
cartes dans l'exécutif et en vidéo
jacob d'annoncer le commission denquête
ces blancs bienvenue dans mon enfance je
dors c'est pour faire des comparaisons
internationales
j'en doute mais quel mépris encore pour
le parlement comment le président de
l'assemblée nationale peut continuer à
se faire humilier de la sorte c'est lui
qui décide de la commission denquête
mais alors il veut une commission
denquête mais surtout on ne doit pas
interroger ministre de la santé de
l'époque et on ne doit pas interroger le
premier 1000c quand même formidable
histoire d'accrocher c'est une
distribution numéro j'ai entendu
beaucoup plus tard mais tout de suite on
dit qu'on met la commission denquête
mais surtout il faut pas les interroger
je comprenais le premier miss est très
occupé les wavre en train de faire sa
campagne municipale qui valait m'bia
aussi donc ils ont quand même autre
chose à faire que de perdre leur temps
devant leur assemblée il vaut mieux
qu'ils soient effectivement en train de
faire leur campagne municipale
enfin tourné dans quelle république
sommes nous le vice-président de la
commission denquête à l'assemblée est
élève ces derniers amman le président du
groupe et rapportera à qui on a dit eric
ciotti damien abad cette semaine à l'air
de dire qu'il ne fallait pas en faire
une commission benalla bis on disait que
ça elle est peut-être plus plus
indulgent à vous entendre ça ne sera pas
le cas c'est la transporte moi je l' ai
toujours dit ça doit être fait dans la
plus grande transparence avec beaucoup
de sérénité et j'avais d'ailleurs à
l'époque souhaitait que ces commission
denquête se fasse plus tard mais le sait
le c'est pas nous c'est la majorité qui
a souhaité qu'elle démarre maintenant
alors on peut pas souhaiter que la
commission d' enquête commence
aujourd'hui et ne pas souhaité
auditionner les principaux acteurs sous
prétexte qu'ils sont en train de faire
leur campagne des municipales
écoutez vos yeux mais j'avoue que je
tombe de l'armoire on marque une
dernière pause et on se retrouve dans un
instant avec christian jacob
christian jacob le président de l air
est toujours avec nous cécile cornudet
va vous interroger sur le 14 juillet qui
va être un petit peu particulier cette
année
oui la cérémonie mettra à l'honneur les
soignants ce que c'est une bonne chose
et est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
massivement augmenté les salaires des
soignants de combien c'est quoi votre
projet là dessus
tout d'abord c'est une bonne chose de
mettre à l'honneur les personnels
soignants sur l'augmentation de salaire
bien évidemment mais mais ça peut pas se
résumer à ça c'est pas un coup de primes
qu'on peut traiter les
dysfonctionnements de notre système de
santé qui ont été mis en exergue
on a bien vu la difficulté qu'il y avait
à la prise en compte à la
complémentarité public privé on a vu le
fonctionnement très administratif des
déserts est qu'ils ont bien souvent
paralysé les actions locales qui était
mené le manque d'autonomie qui pouvait y
avoir dans les établissements donc c'est
vraiment l'ensemble qu'il faut qu'il
faut repenser avec entre autres la
proposition j'évoquais tout à l'heure
sur l'annualisation adultes du temps de
travail qui permet une augmentation du
du salaire et qui ne et qui permet aussi
d'avoir davantage de réactivité dans les
situations de crise telles que tels
qu'on les a vus là mais mais un oui il
faut bien entendu salué l'action des
personnels soignants de la réforme doit
passer par une amélioration du
déroulement de carrière et une
augmentation des des rémunérations et
l'annualisation est une possibilité pour
arriver aussi à cela sur le 14 juillet
christian jacob
pas de défilé militaire cette année
juste une cérémonie place de la concorde
est ce que comme marine le pen vous êtes
choqué qu'il n'y ait pas de défilé
militaire
je pense qu'on pouvait faire un défilé
militaire on vient de le voir récemment
avec l'opération barkan c'est aussi
l'occasion de saluer l'action de ne nous
servirons présente un mais une série
voici sicile et s'il est possible si
j'ai dire s'il ya une institution qui
peut respecter des consignes de sécurité
de distance etc sont bien les militaires
donc je pense quand on aurait sans doute
pu trouver une formule liant les deux
objectivement christian jacob faut-il
accélérer le déconfinement l'épidémie
est sous contrôle c'est ce que dit
depuis quelques jours le le conseil
scientifique est ce qu'il faudrait aller
plus vite sur les écoles où le nombre
d'enfants accueillis est encore très
très restreint est-ce qu'il faut
assouplir les conditions sanitaires
puisque à ce stade l'épidémie à la
maîtrise et il somme non seulement
qu'elles soient maîtrisés mais qu'elle
décroît ce très très rapidement sur les
derniers indications qu'on a eu à partir
de ce moment là je pense qu'il faut
effectivement on puisse redémarrer le
plus rapidement possible et puis un
certain nombre d'incohérences que je
vous disais tout à l'heure
mettez vous à la place de ces
restaurateurs parisiens qui ne peuvent
pas travailler et à côté ça on autorise
une manifestation rassemblant 4 sont
ouvertes à paris mais pas la
restauration intérieure et met d'accord
mais simplement oser beaucoup
d'établissements d'une pas nombreux tous
les établissements n'ont pas de terrasse
ensuite l'équilibré économique ne peut
pas se faire que sur la terrasse il se
fait sur l'ensemble des surfaces de
vente et moi je pense que il faut que
l'on puisse sortir le plus rapidement
possible parce que la reprise économique
va être difficile ça se fera pas par un
claquement de doigts et plus vite on
redémarre et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aussi que le le plan de relance
interviennent vite les entreprises ont
besoin de lisibilité dans l'action
publique
or aujourd'hui avec dire cette addition
de deux plans où chaque jour on nous
fait une annonce on perd en cohérence et
en perd en lisibilité et donc on perd en
efficacité et le projet de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est ce qu'il faut le
prolonger ou le roux l'arrêter comme
c'est prévu en juillet pense que
sérieusement là il faut l'arrêter
moi j'étais pas favorables d'ailleurs
est ce qu'on le prolonge si loin je
pense que là où il ya une seconde vague
en septembre
oui mais derrière ça vous avez
la possibilité de gouverner par
ordonnances vous avez le parlement qui
me complètement de côté à l'occasion
d'un plan de cette importance donc il
faut que le parlement retrouve ses
droits
rapidement et il faut que la machine
économique se remette en route
rapidement et pour ça je pense que
maintenant il faut sortir de l'état
d'urgence on vous entend christian jacob
vous dites aller plus vite relancer
l'activité mais l'opinion semble plutôt
soutenir l'action du premier ministre
dans les sondages il est plutôt avec une
cote de popularité qui augmente ça ça
veut dire que finalement il à pau il a
il a su imposer le bon tempo
d'abord elle est une des plus faibles
d'europe c'est le gouvernement tandis
que le plus impopulaire
c'est ça aussi la réalité si vous voulez
aller sur les sondages bon
particularismes des mais audelà de cela
on veut dire que le premier ministre a
tenu son rang dans cette dans cette
période là et moi je n'ai pas je ne pas
tomber dans une critique facile je pense
simplement que maintenant il faut en
sortir
je pense qu'il faut en sortir parce
qu'avec un dépanneur erronément des mini
d'ailleurs de sas appartient au
président de la république au premier
ministre les deux seules personnes a
décidé là dessus sont de soi on a le
premier unissent décide de quitter soit
le président de la république
choisi de le changer mais ça n'est ni
vous ni moi qui en influence sur ce
sujet et s'est bien débrouillé pardon
dans la dans la période
disons qu'en en miroir du président du
du président de la république touche
tout le monde reconnaît que le travail a
été fait simplement bien souvent ça n'a
pas été suivie d'effet c'est à dire que
si les décisions les orientations
étaient bonnes on a vu l'incapacité sur
le terrain à concrétiser les actions et
c'est là que les collectivités
territoriales ont joué tout ce rôle
parce que le les services déconcentrés
de l'état n'ont pas fonctionné et puis
il y a une tâche la tâche sur les
mensonges au début de la crise christian
jacob
vous disiez fort justement le changement
de premier ministre c'est au président
de la république de le décider
mais vendredi dans marianne on a
découvert que dans la majorité c'est des
propositions notamment celles de gilles
legendre qui est le président du groupe
e la république en marche à l'assembleur
vous même vous avez été longtemps
président de groupe
est ce qu'un président de groupe peut
écrire ça le premier ministre qui ne
s'est pas assez impliqués dans la
gestion de la majorité
bruno le maire qui pour être premier
ministre malgré un faible charisme
aucune personnalité crédible pour être
premier ministre chez les députés
quel regard vous portez sur sur ces
commentaires acides
écoutez c'est c'est hallucinant
hallucinant quand je vous disais que le
président de la république n'avait plus
de prise c'est ça la réalité c'est
l'effondrement l'explosion de sa
majorité de sa majorité parlementaire
avec ses notes la venue des époques
christian jacob ou aussi dans la
majorité a je pense que sarkozy le
groupe s'était fracturé non non non non
absolument pas non c'était dans
l'opposition c'est ce qui va strictement
rien à voir avec ce soit jacques chirac
ou nicolas sarkozy pense que le groupe
parlementaire ont toujours été et est
tenu et là ses propos du premier fin de
du président de groupe qui normalement
doit être celui qui met plutôt du ciment
là ils jouent les apprentis artificiers
il envoie des notes au président de la
république le président de la république
se dépêchent de faire fuiter dans la
presse pour déstabiliser son premier
ministre
enfin c'est une république c'est un
gouvernement qui part à vau l'eau
complètement avec une majorité qui
explose
neuf groupes dits groupes parlementaires
maintenant l'assemblée nationale chacun
avait quinze copains la buvette décide
de créer son groupe tout ça représente
ressemble à quoi
et encore une fois demandé à legendre
gilles legendre de faire cette
proposition par écrit pour la faire
fuiter ensuite cette légèreté
bon enfin attendez tout le monde sait
très bien que c'est l'elysée qui fait
fuiter pour faire pour organiser la
pression contre edouard philippe est
réglé son compte à gilles legendre du
même coup c'est ça c'est ça la réalité
des choses
un dernier mot christian jacob parce
qu'on va arriver au bout de cette
émission
marine le pen ce week-end ces derniers
jours cherchent à récupérer la figure du
général de gaulle auquel vous êtes
attaché dans votre parti politique
elle écrit et que nous sommes au
rassemblement national la continuité des
grandes idées que général de gaulle a
défendu qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette analyse de marine le pen c'est
d'un ridicule de total invraisemblable
comment peut-on dire une chose pareille
et le gaullisme c'est d'abord 1940 c'est
c'est la constance c'est la solidité
c'est l'honneur de la france d'ailleurs
il n'ya pas beaucoup d'amis de la
famille le pen à ce moment là aux côtés
de côté du général de gaulle
ensuite le général de gaulle c'est la
place de la france sur la scène
internationale le rôle éminent de la
france sur la scène internationale
avec cette présence la présence de la
france au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
c'est la force de dissuasion nucléaire
ensuite c'est cette volonté
d'indépendance économique politique et
diplomatique de la france
et puis enfin c'est la cinquième
république et la vème république
c'est la solidité
dans la stabilité gouvernementale qui
est qui qui repose sur la solidité d'une
majorité parlementaire et cette solidité
de la majorité parlementaire
elle est liée au scrutin uninominal à
deux tours c'est exactement le contraire
absolu c'est le contraire vous pouvez
cocher case par case de ce que réclame
madame madame le pen ou monsieur mac ont
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence ici absolue
c'est emmanuel lacroix ce que là vous
êtes d'accord avec elle et on conclura
lazio christian lapeyre ils font la
paire attendait c'est la volonté de la
quatrième république
ce que rêve ce dont rêve madame le pen
et monsieur macron c'est de revenir à la
quatrième république
c'est la négation du gaullisme il
incarne d'ailleurs tous les deux
manières différentes mais il incarne
parfaitement
merci beaucoup christian jacob d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin un bon
dimanche à tous